jeremy scahill the title of the book is
Blackwater so let's begin there what is
Blackwater it sounds kind of sinister
yeah well actually the the name comes
from the the hometown of the company the
area where the company is based in
Moyock North Carolina it was built near
the Great Dismal Swamp and so a lot of
people say how it's an ominous sounding
name it must have something to do with
covert ops but actually it's just named
for the dark waters of the swamp
Blackwater is a company that didn't even
exist about a decade ago and it's since
risen to become one of the most powerful
private actors in the global war on
terror the company provides security for
the top US officials in Iraq including
ambassador Zama Khalil Zod they guard
all the congressional delegations that
go over to Iraq including that of House
Speaker Nancy Pelosi
they protect US regional occupation
offices in Iraq their training forces in
Afghanistan they even deployed in New
Orleans after Hurricane Katrina and this
company really grew out of the war
contractor bonanza that happened after
9/11 the company has seven hundred and
fifty million dollars in State
Department contracts alone but ten years
ago it was a little more than a seven
thousand acre plot on a swamp in North
Carolina and the visions of it's very
wealthy founder a former ex he was an
axe and a me seal so it took off after
9/11 but how did it get started in the
90s Oh ready to get started it was
founded by a guy named Eric Prince and
he came from a very powerful
conservative family in the state of
Michigan his uh his dad used their
company Prince manufacturing as a cash
generating engine to support Republican
causes the Christian conservative
movement in this country and so the
founder of Blackwater grew up in this
household where he saw his dad run a
very successful business and be very
engaged politically with Republican
causes Christian conservative causes he
was actually an intern at George HW
Bush's White House but he complained
that it wasn't conservative enough for
him his dad for instance gave the seed
money to Gary Bower to start the Family
Research Council they were major funders
of James Dobson and his focus on the
family network and Eric Prince was
believed to be one of the wealthiest
people ever to join the US Navy SEALs
and in the mid-1990s his father passed
away and his wife had cancer and so he
had to go back to Michigan to sort of
deal with the personal crisis and his
family and being a seal was no longer in
option and so in 1996 Eric Prince got
together with some other special ops
guys and they started what was
envisioned as a training center for law
enforcement and a sort of sportsman's
paradise but in the early company
literature it's interesting because they
said that they wanted to anticipate
accelerated government outsourcing and
so during the Clinton years Blackwater
won a number of contracts after the
Columbine shooting for instance in 1999
Blackwater built mock high school on
their compound in North Carolina and
they called it are you ready hi and they
trained SWAT teams and local law
enforcement to deal with violence in
schools when the USS Cole was bombed in
2000 Blackwater got a 35 million dollar
contract to Train sailors and how to
protect the force in in open waters as
was the case in the attack on the USS
Cole in Yemen but then when 9/11 hit
Erik Prince the founder of Blackwater
was on Fox News and he said to Bill
O'Reilly I was starting to get a little
cynical about how seriously people took
security and training now the phone is
ringing off the hook
and so Blackwater received a phone call
with those phones ringing off the hook
from the CIA which contracted it to go
into Afghanistan in the early operations
after 9/11 inside the country that was a
black contract and that really kicked
off black waters profile as a private
military company providing private
soldiers to the government so who works
for Blackwater it's it's an interesting
mix of former Special Forces guys all
the way down to general infantry guys
who have left active duty service now
they also have law enforcement former
state troopers there are many tiers of
of Blackwater operators but what
Blackwater is known for in the private
military community is dealing in elite
Special Forces guys so former Navy SEALs
Delta Force Green Berets Army Rangers
and and they are engaged in very
high-profile defense of US officials who
are very much hated for instance in Iraq
and they've been very successful at
keeping these people alive can you make
a lot of money working from home
tremendous amount of money you know I
was talking to a soldier at Fort Hood
the other day and he said you know I was
getting paid $28,000 a year but it's a
little bit better now they're paying me
40,000 to be over in Iraq
that's the monthly take of some of the
best paid
troops for Blackwater some of these guys
are making $1,000 a day tax-free and so
you have a situation where literally
monetary gain has become a private
primary motive for fighting in the war
on terror is it a drain on the US
military does are they finding that the
soldiers are getting out to take this
higher pay oh yeah in fact folks at the
Special Operations Command are saying
that they're in a real crisis right now
because so many people are going over to
the private sector their slang now on
the ground in Baghdad that when you
leave the official US military and go
over to the private contractors they
call it going Blackwater and so I think
a lot of soldiers are looking at these
guys in two ways and one they they look
at them with a sense of awe these guys
run around and these sort of commando
type outfits wraparound sunglasses they
have body armor they have heavy weaponry
they operate with limited rules of
engagement if any and so I think that
there's there's a sort of they're
impressed by them on the other hand I
think that it really drains the morale
of the troops because they see these
guys running around making in a week
what they make in a couple months and I
think they say well why you know why is
it is my life worth less than theirs why
is it that they're being paid so much
money tax-free heavy weaponry they don't
run around with the same weapons that
the US military has access to do they no
well I I think in some cases Blackwater
has more sophisticated weaponry one of
the stories that I tell in the book is
of a Blackwater contractor who had been
on Paul Bremer's detail in the early
stages of the occupation he got into a
firefight on the side of a road with
some Iraqis and he shot them with a
blended metal bullet now these are
munitions that are not allowed for use
by active duty US forces he's shot in
Iraqi he says in the buttocks and it
exploded the left side of his stomach
and when the military heard about it
they actually wrote him and said that
they were going to court-martial him
until they found out that he was
Blackwater and not an official part of
the US force in Iraq well that brings up
the issue of whose laws are these
contractors responsible to right that's
a great question and I think a lot of
people find it disturbing to know that
we have about a hundred thousand
contractors in Iraq right now according
to the Department of Defense the
Government Accountability Office says
about forty eight thousand there are
about four
8,000 employees of private military
firms operating in Iraq there are no
effective laws that govern them one of
the last things Paul Bremer did before
he left Iraq was to issue an edict known
as order 17 which immunized contractors
from domestic prosecution in the country
these contractors also until now have
not been subjected to the Uniform Code
of Military Justice commonly known as
the court-martial system the law that
theoretically governs contractors on the
battlefield is the military
extraterritorial jurisdiction Act of
2000 which basically said that
contractors that are accompanying the
Armed Forces are working for the Armed
Forces shall be subjected to US law in
other words prosecutor would go over to
Iraq investigate a crime or a violation
they would interview witnesses interview
victims and then they would take that
contractor into custody bring them back
to the United States and prosecute them
for that crime in in a US Court out of
the 100,000 contractors in Iraq there's
been one indictment and that just
happened recently and it wasn't an armed
contractor and so there are no effective
laws now right now in Congress the
Democrats are trying to expand that
military extraterritorial jurisdiction
Act to include all contractors in Iraq
not just those working for the
Department of Defense because the
problem is this Blackwater largely
doesn't work for the Department of
Defense in Iraq it works for the State
Department and so the current laws on
the books would provide for Blackwater
to essentially be above the law there's
no effective law governing their
presence in Iraq well you show you there
48,000 armed
no not all of them are armed there are
48 thousand employees of private
military firms of those about let's say
half are actually engaged in some sort
of armed activity and all those don't
work for Blackwater no Blackwater
Blackwater is not I call them the most
powerful mercenary army they're not the
biggest they're not the most profitable
you have massive companies publicly
traded companies DynCorp Triple Canopy
that are bigger than Blackwater
Blackwater is just the closest to the
throne in the United States and so they
have 2300 men deployed in nine countries
around the world and they have another
20,000 contractors at the ready for
deployment at a moment's notice
closest to the throne what do you mean
well the the leadership of Blackwater is
an interesting mix of political backrub
anq rollers of the president the founder
of Blackwater in his immediate
we have given about a quarter of a
million dollars in publicly identifiable
funds to federal campaigns for a
Republican causes the vice chairman of
the company is a very well known spy his
name is J Cofer black former head of
counterterrorism at the CIA
former ambassador at large on
counterterrorism
he's a major power player the man who
caught Carlos the Jackal and the guy who
told President Bush I'll bring you Osama
bin Laden's head and a box with dry ice
you know they have Joseph Schmidt's the
former Pentagon inspector general whose
job it was to oversee this war
contractor bonanza who then leaves
office in 2005 under fire of all people
from chuck Grassley the Iowa Republican
saying that he covered up investigations
he hadn't done his job
there was a indication from Grassley
that he'd actually sort of intervened in
the writing of a Justice Department
press release and so Blackwater is
peppered with a number of former senior
officials and political allies of the
President
so it's well-connected but what what
kind of reputation does it have in the
business is it a top of the line or is
this a fly-by-night operation
Ono the Blackwater is is extraordinary
and it's forward-thinking I mean these
guys are at the cutting edge of
fourth-generation warfare they've at
every turn proven themselves to be
visionaries in predicting trends in
global warfare and I think for that
reason they're very respected in the
federal bureaucracy I think among the
military it gets a little bit more
complicated I think on the one hand
Blackwater is viewed as an elite force
they're dealing with guys who were the
cream of the crop of the US military
former Navy SEALs and I think it
trickles down to the soldiers as well as
the generals I think that there's a two
ways of looking at them on the one hand
they're very good at what they do on the
other hand they are sort of rogue
operators and I think there have been
numerous occasions where US military
officials have gotten into conflicts
with Blackwater and other contractors on
the road these guys drive around they'll
shoot at Iraqi vehicles in fact one of
the the senior US military people on the
ground in Iraq whose job it was to
oversee the reformation of the Iraqi
security forces himself had been in
Iraqi vehicles that had been shot at by
Blackwater
so I think I think it's a complicated
dynamic on the ground but blackwater
also has proven remarkably adept at
greasing the wheels behind the scenes
once they became a vendor to the federal
government it become a the game becomes
who you know behind the scenes and how
well you you wax the system well family
say a brigade commander for the US Army
in Iraq and I'm responsible for a
certain sector of let's say Baghdad and
Blackwater is also operating in that
sector do i as the brigade commander
have control over what Blackwater does
that's a great question and you know
that one of the the internal reports
that was done in December of 2006 by the
GAO looked at issues with contractors
and one of the main crises that they
that was identified by that report was
this issue of command and control who
ultimately is in charge now the military
would say we're engaged in a in an overt
military operation and the general
should be in charge of what's happening
on the ground
Blackwater though is working for the
State Department their one job is to
keep Zama Khalil's out alive and they're
going to do it by any means necessary
and that creates a real conflict of
interest between the active duty forces
on the ground and the private forces
from Blackwater you used a phrase I
hadn't heard before fourth-generation
warfare what do you mean well one of the
things that we've seen happen since the
Bush administration you know came to
power was that Donald Rumsfeld
implemented this small footprint
approach the idea was to accelerate the
use of the private sector but also to
engage in high-end technology and
smaller private forces and so Blackwater
for instance is marketing a unmanned spy
drone they're marketing surveillance
blimps that could be used domestically
in the US as well as as abroad and I
think it you know I thought at the heart
of fourth-generation warfare is looking
at how to use the most advanced parts of
war technology to limit casualties on
the ground but also to advanced military
technology and Blackwater has been at
the cutting edge of that we hear over
and over that the United States has the
most powerful military
in the world in recorded history so why
does the most powerful military in
history have to hire another firm a
military contractor to do what soldiers
do I think that's a question that a lot
of people in the military are asking
right now I think that the Bush
administration enjoys using these
private forces because they provide a
great deal of political cover the deaths
of Blackwater contractors are not
counted in the official death poll some
780 contractors have been killed in Iraq
I actually think the number is higher
but we know that because the contractors
use something called the defense base
act to provide insurance to their
employees and their contractors and so
the Department of Labor has determined
that 780 have been killed in Iraq 7600
have been wounded but more importantly
their vast numbers don't get counted in
the total occupation force so we have a
hundred and thirty thousand active duty
US troops on the ground in Iraq and then
we have a hundred thousand contractors
most Americans don't know that and so
that effectively doubles the occupation
force through the use of the private
sector also these forces their crimes go
unreported undocumented unpunished and
and I think that it provides a lot of
political cover to the Bush
administration it also in this era of
great secrecy that we live in
further shrouds the operations in
secrecy the operations of a company like
Blackwater Congress has found it almost
impossible to determine what it looks
like in Iraq Blackwater has repeatedly
refused to hand over documents to
Congress Blackwater's operations are not
subjected subjected to Freedom of
Information Act requests you know we
know that the the military is
court-martialed soldiers for violations
in Iraq and at the same time these
hundred thousand private forces in Iraq
are subjected not to the UCMJ and not to
any effective civilian law how about for
yourself how hard was it to find out
information about extraordinarily
difficult I filed many many Freedom of
Information Act requests and I tried to
build this complete of a picture as I
could as to how much of the federal
budget PI Blackwater was eating the
companies executives refused to go
record with me I did talk to myself and
my researcher former executives at
Blackwater former guys who had served
with Blackwater the families of men who
had served with Blackwater and tried to
present as full of a picture as I could
I also relied heavily for the official
story from Blackwater on the excellent
reporting of local reporters in Virginia
and North Carolina in Blackwater's
backyard did you interview Eric Prince I
had one interaction with Eric Prince
where I tried to talk to him I ran into
him at a conference at the American
Enterprise Institute and I tried to
question him and he literally ran away
from me he jumped over a row of chairs
and I was sort of chasing him around a
room with a microphone trying to get him
to answer questions but he didn't he
didn't say one word to me what you're
describing is basically outsourcing and
outsourcing is one of the hallmarks of
globalization so is it just
globalization coming to the military or
is there something else driving this no
I don't think it's just globalization
coming to the military I think in many
ways I think Blackwater embodies the
very scenario that President Eisenhower
warned against when he talked about the
rise of the military-industrial complex
where you have companies whose entire
livelihood depends on violent conflict
and I think that is one of the scariest
developments you know we I think we
think of the military in this country as
being defensive in nature and I think
that's why so many people join the
militaries they believe that they're
defending their country but a company
like Blackwater has a sort of neo
patriotic recipe that they feed to their
men where on the one hand they say we
are you're defending your country and on
the other hand they say and you're going
to get paid very well for doing it and
so what it does is it really takes the
sincerity out of the equation of
defending your country and I see it as a
real subversion of democratic processes
in this country because and this answers
directly your question the Bush
administration is waging this offensive
war in Iraq and in order to do it it
needs private forces because so many
Americans are against it the military is
in a real crisis right now : Powell
declared that the active-duty military
is about broken and so where do you turn
well when you don't have the support of
your of your country through swelling of
the ranks of the active-duty military
you turn to the private sector
Blackwater for instance as much as they
want to portray themselves as an
all-american pie operation has recruited
mercenaries from Chile from Colombia
from Bulgaria from Fiji from around the
world so the you fail to build a
coalition of willing nations you build a
coalition of billing companies I tell
one story in the book about Chile this
was a country 92% of the population was
against the Iraq war Chile was a
rotating member of the Security Council
opposing the invasion of Iraq and
Blackwater and other companies went in
and hired 750 Chilean mercenaries in
contravention of the will of Chile and
its government and sent them to Iraq
that's a subversion not just of the
American democratic process but of
nation-states around the world
so you call this a coalition of the
billing well actually PW singer who's
the great scholar on this issue and
wrote the definitive book corporate
warriors on on contractors and the
contractor system calls them the
coalition of the billing and I think a
lot of us have picked up on that and
enjoy that phrase now when Eisenhower
was talking about the
military-industrial complex he was
talking about the the firm's which build
equipment right for the US military so
and if you look at it that way
outsourcing is as old as a military so
what's the difference between hiring
Blackwater to be a security consultant
for you in hiring Boeing Lockheed Martin
to build an airplane for you right I I
think that the idea with with with using
the private sector to to provide
hardware for the military or weapons
systems is that you have competition in
the marketplace and so you're going to
get the best product available that's
the theory behind it when you now are
sort of dealing in in human life which
Blackwater and other companies do you're
putting private actors onto a
battlefield it'd be one thing if there
were effective laws governing them and
and the US military was in a crisis and
we were engaged in a defensive war well
not you know that's not true at all
we're not engaged in a defensive war and
and so the real problem with with this
explosion now of the military-industrial
complex is that they have crossed the
line from simply manufacturing bombs and
aircraft and guns to actually providing
soldiers who are totally unaccountable
and that that is
that that I think it's the very spirit
of why Eisenhower was was making those
warnings that you have a situation where
a politically connected company gets
very lucrative contracts to provide
forces whose operations are shrouded in
secrecy it's it's it's at its very
essence it's anti-democratic some people
will say that it makes no sense to train
a soldier teach matter we demamp jump
out of an airplane all the things
soldiers do and then put them to work
mowing lawns at the base isn't that
what's going on here you've got soldiers
who are trained to operate as a unit
communicate all the things that go into
an organized military operation
why happen standing around doing
security for Jerry Bremer or the US
ambassador right that's that's one of
the arguments that that the private
sector makes in supporting this cause I
I think though that the that we need to
look specifically at Iraq because this
is where it's really exploded the fact
is that they there are no longer enough
active duty forces to sustain the
occupation and so they've accelerated
the use of the private sector and the
problem lies where Blackwater is now
doing a job in guarding the senior US
diplomats in Iraq that traditionally was
done by the diplomatic security corps
that's been dramatically outsourced and
you're creating a tier system where
you're saying our active duty forces
aren't as important monetarily as these
private forces and I think you create a
real crisis of morale within the
military when you have the private
sector paid in some cases exponentially
more than your active duty forces and
again I think we have to to put as our
priority the democratic process in this
country and the fact is that when you
have forces that are not accountable
whose operations Congress can't even get
a hold of that's a real problem and so
it's not just a simple matter of
crunching numbers and whether or not the
active-duty military should do a job
privatization is the real issue and and
the dangers that comes with that of such
a radical privatization where the danger
is that there's no oversight and I think
that's what Congress is starting to
realize is at play I remember the first
time I sort of tumbled to the importance
these military contractors in the
conduct of military operations was in
Bosnia and I went to the base the main
base of Tuzla
and all of the foods services were
contracted out in the base in fact I
think had been built by a contractor but
where did they that's that's basically
providing logistical services and
there's an old saying that amateurs talk
strategy professionals talk talk
logistics have you been able to identify
a crossover line where these contractors
became integral to US military
operations yes
well in part first of all they this this
all really started in its current form
when Dick Cheney was defense secretary
under George HW Bush and one of the last
things he did you probably recall David
before leaving office was to commission
a study from a division of Halliburton
the company he would go on to head and
that study looked at how to greater
privatize the military bureaucracy but
it was the servicing of the military as
you mentioned the laundry the the food
services anything that wasn't combat in
its orientation in the mid-1990s there
was one contract that the Clinton
administration authorized that sort of
changed the equation a bit Clinton
allowed a private military firm called M
PRI military professional resources
incorporated based in Virginia to go
into Croatia during the Yugoslav Civil
War and to train the Croatian military
the Croatian military turned around and
carried out a blitzkrieg called
Operation storm and lightning in which
they expelled about a quarter of a
million Serbs from from the krai inna
the New York Times called that the
single greatest ethnic cleansing of the
war but what it did is it turned the
Yugoslav civil war in favor of the u.s.
position and it happened by putting a
few boots on the ground a couple of
retired military guys who talked
strategy with the Croatian military and
they were able to effect change in a
very radical way on behalf of the US
goals in the region and that that is
viewed I think in the industry and among
the scholars who studied this as a real
turning point they actually were on the
ground engaging with a foreign military
that was an ally of the United States
and it was a successful
operation from the viewpoint of the
Clinton administration now when Dick
Cheney was defense secretary that was of
course when the Cold War ended and the
biggest issue he dealt with was what was
called the downsizing of US military
scaling it back now that she no longer
had to compete against the the Soviet
military and the size of the army was
basically cut in half so isn't this a
logical extension is his commissioning
these studies isn't that a logical
extension of the end of the Cold War oh
I think that that's very much what
Cheney and Rumsfeld certainly envisioned
I mean I think that their global view
when it comes to the running of the war
machine has to run it more like a
venture capital firm than a bureaucracy
in fact you may recall in September of
2001 on September 10th 2001 Rumsfeld
gave this major address in which he said
that governments can't die and so we
need to find other incentives to keep
competition alive
and I think that they're very militant
disciples of the free market system and
they believe in the private sectors role
in the government period not just in the
military it happened I think too late to
get into your book but when David
Petraeus was going through his
confirmation hearings he was to be the
new commander in Iraq he was asked if he
had enough troops and with with the
surge and the Iraqi forces that are
being added to Baghdad he figured he was
going to have 85,000 troops when
traditional counterinsurgency doctrine
told him he needed 120 thousand just for
Baghdad and his his answer to this gap
was well there are tens of thousands of
contractors doing jobs that we don't
have to do which I think does make the
point of how integral they have they
have become in these operations but what
would happen if pick pick your
contractor Halliburton Blackwater
whoever decided it was simply too
dangerous to operate there in
we say hey you have to stay we need you
yeah I'd be very surprised if that
happened I know the US military nor the
administration could order a company to
stay in the war zone and that's one of
the things on the ground that that
differentiates a soldier from a private
soldier if a soldier abandons his post
he's going to be court-martialed if a
private soldier says forget this I'm off
the battlefield he just leaves and but
but that it's it's it's too profitable
there's there's no way that these
companies are going to pull out of Iraq
the only way they would pull out of Iraq
as if Congress legislated it bush is not
going to pull them out in fact the
Democrats in their legislation could
have 40,000 troops in Iraq at the end of
2008 and an unlimited number of
contractors this isn't even on the
agenda and and you know Rumsfeld in
February of 2006 in the Pentagon's
quadrennial review for the first time
identified contractors as a fish Allah
the u.s. total force this was a
legitimacy they couldn't have dreamed
off before we're going to go to a break
afterwards and several other c-span
programs are available for download as
podcasts more with Jeremy Scahill and
David Martin in a moment author and
journalist Alexander Coburn live on
in-depth Sunday beginning at noon
Eastern in addition to his column for
the nation and being co-editor for the
political newsletter counterpunch mr.
Coburn has written over a dozen books
such as corruptions of empire the
politics of anti-semitism and a dimes
worth of difference his latest and times
the death of the Fourth Estate discusses
that news reporting is infiltrated with
government and corporate agendas join
our live three-hour discussion as booked
TVs in depth welcomes Alexander Coburn
Sunday at noon eastern on c-span 2 and
in may our in-depth guest is author and
University of Texas professor Marvin
Lasky
for a complete listing of book TV
programs and times go online to book TV
org
afterwards with Jeremy Scahill and David
Martin continues just going to the
little bio of you on the cover here of
the book Jeremy Scahill is a Polk
award-winning investigative journalist
what is the Polk award and what did you
win it for I won the Polk award it's
it's one of the more prestigious awards
for in journalism it's given by Long
Island University and I won that award
for a documentary I did with my
colleague Amy Goodman about the Chevron
oil corporations operations in the night
the oil-rich Niger Delta of Nigeria we
went over there in the summer of 1998
and we documented an incident in which
the Chevron Corporation had provided its
own company helicopters to one of the
most notorious units of the Nigerian
security forces to go in and suppress a
protest on one of the company's barges
and some people were killed and injured
in it and so we did an hour-long
documentary about Chevron that ended up
winning the Polk award for uh for
foreign radio reporting you're also a
frequent contributor to the Nation
magazine I think most people have heard
of the nation but just give us a brief
description the Nation magazine is the
oldest political news weekly in the
United States and it's a mixture of
opinion and investigative reporting so
my my particular role at the Nation
magazine has been to investigate private
military companies like Blackwater the
editor as Katrina vanden Heuvel before
that it was Victor Navasky both of them
very well-known progressive thinkers and
writers and says you're now a writing
fellow at the nation Institute I assume
that's associated with the Nation
magazine yes and it's published by
nation book yes so I think I had the
connection I'm a one beat guy yes I
think well most people if they've heard
of Blackwater before they heard about it
because of what happened in Fallujah in
2004 so explain to me what happened in
Fallujah in many ways it was the day the
war turned it was March 31st 2004 9:30
in the morning
convoy
by Blackwater made its way into the
center of the city at the front of the
convoy was a pyro Jeep with a reinforced
bumper not an armored vehicle sitting in
that chief were two Blackwater
contractors behind that there were three
empty flatbed trucks being driven by
Iraqi drivers and then taking up the
rear was another pyro Jeep with two
other Blackwater contractors and their
mission that day was to go to one end of
Fallujah pick up some kitchen equipment
and bring it back to the other end of
Fallujah at 9:30 they roll into the
center of the city they hit some sort of
a roadblock and within moments the rear
vehicle the rear pyro Jeep is attacked
by Iraqi insurgents they shoot up the
vehicle they begin to tear apart the men
inside the lead vehicle turns around to
either get off the X meaning to get off
the scene or to turn around and help
their comrades and they too are
overtaken by insurgents and within
moments the original attackers disappear
into the side streets of Fallujah and a
mob descends on the convoy and they
literally tear the men apart they burn
the men they loot their bodies and take
their possessions and hundreds of people
are dancing in the streets they tie some
of them to the back of a car drive them
through the streets of Fallujah and
eventually two of their bodies charred
lifeless bodies were hung from a bridge
over the Euphrates River one young man
in the crowd held up a homemade sign
that said Fallujah is the graveyard of
the Americans and for many people is the
first that they'd ever heard of
contractors operating in Iraq not to
mention private military contractors in
fact some of the headlines that they say
for American civilians mutilated in Iraq
but they weren't civilians nor were they
active-duty military they were private
military contractors for Blackwater and
what happened after that was the siege
of Fallujah US military surrounded the
city III actually think that the Marines
didn't want to take the kind of approach
that ended up happening as a result of
the of the Blackwater ambushed the Bush
administration ordered a massive attack
on the city and that was the first of
several sieges of Fallujah they carried
out 37,000 airstrikes destroyed 19,000
buildings hundreds of people were killed
scores of US soldiers were killed in the
various sieges of Fallujah as well but
what what it did David is it inflame the
Iraqi
distance because at that time you
already had moqtada al-sadr Shiite
forces rising up against the US in Iraq
you had the Sunnis beginning to
increasingly engage in resistance and
Paul Bremer had fired about a quarter of
a million Iraqi soldiers as part of his
deification program so you had a real
you know you had a real volatile
situation the Fallujah ambush happens
the u.s. lays siege to the city and and
all of a sudden you have an outbreak of
very overt violent resistance in Iraq
you say they were going through Fallujah
to pick up kitchen equipment right a
Blackwater was was operating on a
contract with the world's largest
catering services company it's a company
called ESS and who ESS was ultimately
contracted to whether it was KBR or
floor would become the subject of a
multi-year investigation by
representative Henry Waxman so these men
literally died for pots and pans and
their families all thought they were
going over to Iraq to protect Paul
Bremer that's what Blackwater was doing
at the time in Iraq and so when it
turned out that they in fact were dying
for kitchen equipment these families
started to ask some very serious
questions about what their loved ones
were doing over there my first question
would be what was anybody doing in
Fallujah in an armored vehicle right the
US military certainly wouldn't have gone
into into Fallujah in two pierrot jeeps
with reinforced bumpers and and so one
of the things that's happened is that
the families of those four guys have
sued Blackwater and what's come out of
their lawsuit is some very interesting
facts about that mission that day
according to the contract they operated
under they were supposed to have armored
vehicles they were supposed to have
three men to a vehicle a driver a
navigator and a rear gunner who would be
armed with a heavy saw machine gun they
only had two guys to the vehicle meaning
they had no rear gunner they should have
been in the armored vehicles they say
that they weren't provided maps of the
area that they weren't given a chance to
do a pre-trip risk assessment and what
the families of those four guys alleges
that Blackwater sent them in a haphazard
way on that mission to cut corners and
save one and a half million dollars and
they say the Blackwater was trying to
impress this company ESS they had just
won the contract from a competing
private military firm and so you know
you have the situation where these guys
are like sitting ducks in the center of
Fallujah I think most I think the Iraqis
had attacked them believe that they were
either CIA or Mossad where does that
lawsuit today I was filed in January of
2005 in state court in North Carolina
where black waters headquartered and
Blackwater has enlisted some very
powerful lawyers the original lawyer for
Blackwater on the case was none other
than Fred fielding who's now the White
House Counsel at defending bush their
current lawyer of record is Kenneth
Starr the man who led the impeachment
charge against President Clinton and
Blackwater has never disputed or even
taken on the specific allegations of the
lawsuit it's a wrongful death lawsuit
rather Blackwater has tried to have the
case dismissed
and the argument Blackwater puts forward
is we're part of the u.s. total force we
Rumsfeld said it February of 2006 so we
should be entitled to the same immunity
from civilian litigation as the US
military is and Blackwater twice has has
appealed to the US Supreme Court which I
should point out is dominated by
Republican appointees and and the Chief
Justice is an appointee of the current
president and yet the Supreme Court
rejected Blackwater's appeals so it
appears now as though this case is going
to go forward in state court in North
Carolina where I understand there would
be no cap on potential damages and the
lawyers for those four families are
comparing it to the tobacco litigation
of the 1990s saying that once the first
domino falls it could cause shockwaves
to ride through the industry in fact a
KBR has filed an amicus brief in the
case which way which gives you a sense
of how important it is to that industry
have they specified the amount of
damages they're seeking not yet and the
Marines were just outside Fallujah right
did the Greens come to the aid of these
Blackwater guys that were caught in that
ambush no the Marines and I tell the
story in the book I think the Marines
made a determination that if that that
it was already done the guys were dead
and hanging from the bridge and if they
had gone in in some kind of a
heavy-handed manner I think that they
felt that they would have been
subjecting US soldiers to unnecessary
severe danger and I think that the
Marines made a calculation that they had
to let the scene play out and so it
wasn't an immediate response and the
Marines
and also the 82nd airborne both had been
trying various approaches to dealing
with Fallujah and I think that they were
trying to take what they call the hearts
and minds approach to the city rather
than what ended up happening which was a
crushing of the city if that had been
Marine unit that had been ambushed I can
almost guarantee you the Marines would
have gone in and it's interesting
because I believe the previous morning
Marines had been ambushed had been
ambushed and killed and the Marines did
come in - outside of the city to do a
recovery operation so yes I mean I think
it's interesting that the guy that these
guys were out in the desert on the night
of March 30th these Blackwater guys the
day before the ambush and they got lost
and they actually made contact with a
military base and I quote one source in
the book as saying that when they
arrived at the military base they
wouldn't tell any of the commanders what
their mission was and one of the
commanders on the base said that they
were like Cowboys and I you know so
there could have been a lot of
resentment toward them I don't know if
that personally isn't why they went in I
think they didn't go in because of what
the commander said that it would have
just subjected Marines to unnecessary
violence when the damage had already
been done what did the Blackwater people
know about conditions in Fallujah before
they tried to drive through I think
everyone in Iraq knew that Fallujah was
a no-go zone and was a dangerous place
it had been the scene of intense
fighting already between US forces and
Iraqis that are also been some serious
crackdowns inside the city on Iraqi
demonstrations in fact the the contract
that governed their mission specifically
named Fallujah as a dangerous area of
the country and and talked about the
threat of Fallujah what these individual
men knew about Fallujah I don't know I
would imagine that they had the kind of
knowledge that everyone on the ground
had that Fallujah is a pretty dangerous
place although at least one of those
guys on that mission hadn't even been in
Iraq more than a few days before he
found himself in the middle of what some
people would say was the most dangerous
city in the world do these contractors
have access to US intelligence at some
level I mean the individual guys on the
ground don't but there there is a
privatized Green Zone within the Green
Zone where there's some limited
coordination of the private military
companies amongst each other and so they
share information
they have daily updates on one what's
going on in various parts of the country
but I think that there's a lot of
tension between the official US military
and the contractors there's also
indications that the contractors maybe
even have better intelligence in some
cases and are not bound by the same
kinds of chain of command issues after a
Blackwater helicopter was brought down
in January in Iraq one of the pilots his
brother had been killed in that
operation he also was a Blackwater pilot
wrote an article in which he said that
you know when people are really in
trouble in Iraq they don't call the US
military they call Blackwater because we
can respond faster you mentioned the
downing of the Blackwater helicopter on
are there other incidents in which
Blackwater personnel have been engaged
in direct military combat right there
have been at least three or four
ambushes on Blackwater convoys and then
I tell one story which I find
particularly disturbing it happened on
April 4th 2004 just five days after the
Fallujah ambush so remember you know the
Blackwater guys are at the center of an
increasingly outrage Sunni resistance in
Fallujah after the killing of four of
its men and at the same time Paul Bremer
was really intent on this handover of
sovereignty happening on June 30th of
2004 he wanted to hand over sovereignty
and get out of Iraq and and so the the
Bremer and the administration the Bush
administration made a determination we
have to crush the Sunni resistance but
we also have to deal with moqtada
al-sadr the leader of the the perhaps
the most powerful Shiite resistance
groups the the mehdi army and as as the
Fallujah incident was happening Bremer
orders the arrest of one of muqtada
al-sadr staff deputies and and they
believed that he was being held in Nadja
so al Sadr swallowers march on Nadja
hundreds and hundreds of them and they
descend on the u.s. occupation office in
Nadja of the Coalition Provisional
Authority building and lo and behold
it's being guarded by Blackwater so on
this morning of April 4th 2004 this
massive demonstration takes place
there's about a half a dozen Blackwater
troops on the roof of the CPA building
and by chance there were a handful of
Salvadoran soldiers who were part of the
Coalition of the Willing and active duty
US Marine a guy named corporal Lonnie
young
so this guy corporal Lonnie young finds
himself on the roof with Blackwater guys
and Salvadoran troops and they're
looking down into the crowd there are
varying stories as to how the shooting
happened but it did start had you know
it did happen the Blackwater guys would
say that the they were fired on from the
crowd journalists on the scene say that
concussion grenades had been fired from
the roof where the Blackwater guys were
and that that started the fighting in
any case a gun battle begins
Lonnie young this Marine has his heavy
machine gun pointed into the crowd he
says and I got the official Marine
account from from Lonnie Young's
testimony he says he has a guy in his
sight with an ak-47 he wants to open
fire on him but there's no commanding
officer on the scene and so he says to
the Blackwater mercenaries sir I've
acquired a target with your permission I
want to open fire and the Blackwater guy
gives the go-ahead to an active duty US
Marine to open fire on an Iraqi
protester armed he says and so that day
it was Blackwater that was in charge of
Salvadoran soldiers it was Blackwater
that was in charge of an active duty US
Marine that to me embodies the serious
lines that have been crossed in fact at
one point during that operation
Blackwater called for reinforcements
from Paul Bremer's Blackwater security
detail and they sent their little bird
helicopters to bring in reinforcements
to the rooftop in Nadja for this
day-long firefight I guess you could
argue whether it's a good or a bad thing
to have have these contractors but or
maybe it's just a necessary thing but it
definitely is a phenomenon of 21st
century warfare at least as practiced by
the United States and you say now
Rumsfeld has officially declared as a
matter of policy that these contractors
are integral to US operations do you
think that's a with malice aforethought
or do you think that we just stumbled
into this well I I definitely think that
the companies themselves were engaged in
in a very serious business plan for a
long time I think that war is profitable
and that that in and of itself is a real
problem that monetary gain is a motive
for armed
that and and for Rumsfeld I think that
he himself has spent his career working
on behalf of the cause of privatization
both he and Dick Cheney you know I don't
I don't mean to presume you know to know
what Rumsfeld thinks but I know from
from hit the publicly available
statements and writings of Donald
Rumsfeld that this was a man who
believed in running the Pentagon and its
war machine like a business like a
corporation and I think that this is
very much a product of that you know
that there's a necessary
I think resistance to privatization when
you when you look at government services
and essential services and I think that
this administration has opened the door
wide as wide as I think it's ever been
in history to these private companies
coming in and the real danger is they're
dealing in human life they're dealing in
war they're dealing in national security
issues
these are life-and-death issues and when
you put it into the private sector and
away from public oversight and
transparency it creates a Frankenstein
laboratory type atmosphere which i think
is playing out in a very scary way in
Iraq right now but who's driving this
the companies or the Defense Department
is all of it well I don't know I don't
think it's the Defense Department i I
think that the that the administration
has this administration that has been
more anti military than most
administrations in history they've
subjected they force these commanders on
the ground into totally unwinnable
situations this is a political war this
is an engagement for national security
of the United States this is an
offensive aggressive war and I think it
defeats the the core reason why a lot of
people join the military we hear
testimony after testimony from soldiers
on the ground who don't know why they're
over there and and Blackwater knows why
it's over there
Blackwater is over there to be at the
vanguard of an offensive war protecting
the most senior US officials in Iraq
that to me is a problem and then when
you look at the fact that they're
bankrolling the politicians that press
most passionately for the war then you
see a sort of system that I think raises
a lot of serious questions put aside for
a moment the whole debate over whether
we should have gotten into this war in
the first place just accept that we are
where we are
could we
be fighting this war without Blackwater
and the other military contracting firms
I don't think that the Bush
administration would be able to sustain
the occupation of Iraq without
Blackwater and the other private
military firms and that's the exact
reason why I think there's a serious
problem with it I don't I don't think
that the American people believe in this
war anymore I don't think that the
military believes in this war and so
they the Bush administration needs the
private sector they need companies like
Blackwater and KBR and Triple Canopy and
DynCorp they need these companies to
keep the war going and and and that to
me is one of the most dramatic examples
of how dangerous these developments have
been you no longer rely on your
citizenry to wage wars you rely on
private companies and and that in and of
itself I think is a serious problem you
rattled off some names eroge
describe to me the leaders in this
industry well I mean Halliburton is is
probably the most famous you know war
contractor and a lot of people pick on
Halliburton because of Dick Cheney's
connection to to the company and they
talk about the cronyism Halliburton was
a very successful company when Bill
Clinton was president and Clinton was
was a major supporter of privatization
of the military bureaucracy and so
Halliburton has emerged as the the
largest contractor in the war and its
former subsidiary KVR
these are come this is a company and the
two of them together that have 16
billion dollars plus in contracts for
the Iraq war DynCorp is a company that
is a private military company like
Blackwater that you probably encountered
when you were in Bosnia DynCorp was
heavily involved with the the wars in
the Balkans continues to be a major war
contractor on the ground in Iraq but I
sort of look at DynCorp as like the
Walmart of private security whereas
Blackwater is sort of like the you know
it's it's it's kind of like the Prada I
mean these these are the this is the
these are high-end guys DynCorp provides
a wide variety of soldiers from various
backgrounds Blackwater provides elite
soldiers and so you you have KBR
Halliburton in Blackwater I think become
very interesting because they're so
politically connected to the Bush
administration but in reality those two
companies are two in a sea of a lot of
war contractors that are making a lot of
money
I remember during Abu Ghraib it turned
out that a lot of the people under
investigation were not in fact MPs but
were contractors who were working as
translators for the interrogation teams
right and there there's there are
lawsuits now that have stemmed from that
civilian lawsuits um the the companies
that have been identified as allegedly
being involved at Abu Ghraib Titan khaki
I even though you raised that I still
think many Americans are unaware of the
fact that it wasn't just Lindy England
who is at Abu Ghraib you know and that's
one of the real problems here it's the
the the grunts on the ground are being
prosecuted or court-martialed for
infractions that appear to go very high
up the chain of command and in the case
of contractors they're not being
prosecuted either and so oftentimes it's
just the you know these kids who signed
up to be in the Pennsylvania National
Guard to go and stop floods and find
themselves in the middle of some
hellhole somewhere and they're really
the ones who are the scapegoats for a
much much bigger scandal so we've talked
almost exclusively about the role of
these firms in Iraq where else are they
at work for the u.s. government well one
one last thing I wanted to say you know
to go back to your other point forty
cents of every dollar that's being spent
on the occupation of Iraq is going to
private military to war contractors not
just private military contractors four
billion dollars has been spent on
private security services in Iraq alone
now companies like Blackwater
increasingly have their sights set on
domestic deployments inside of the
United States I was down in New Orleans
after Hurricane Katrina hit I was
standing on a corner on Bourbon Street
in the French Quarter talking to two New
York City police officers I'm from New
York and an unmarked car speeds up next
to us and out of the car pop four just
bulky guys wearing flak jackets khaki
uniforms m4 machine guns another pistol
strapped to their legs and they come up
to the cops and they say you know where
are the rest of the Blackwater guys and
the New York police officers say oh
there's a lot of them they're down the
street and they tell them the hotel
where they are and then they get back
into the car and they speed off no
license plates on the car and I said to
the to the police officers Blackwater
even like the guys in Iraq and he said
oh yeah they're all over the place here
so I found some of these Blackwater guys
on the street and just struck up a
conversation with them and I said and so
what are you guys doing down here what's
your mission and they said we
here to confront criminals and stop
looters and I said under whose authority
are you down here and kind of fumbled
with each other and then one guy pulls a
gold law enforcement badge he says I was
deputized by the governor of the state
of Louisiana and I was saying you know
you guys on federal contract down here
you're in a state contract and they said
well we can't really talk about it but
we're sleeping in a camp organized by
the Department of Homeland Security so I
looked into it a little bit further and
I was able to determine that in fact the
Department of Homeland Security had
hired Blackwater to engage in security
operations in New Orleans after
Hurricane Katrina and when I got the
contracts it turns out that Blackwater
guys in the ground had told me they were
getting paid three hundred and fifty
dollars a day Blackwater was billing the
federal government nine hundred and
fifty dollars per day per man four
Blackwater operators deployed in the
hurricane zone at one point David they
had six hundred men stretched from Texas
through Mississippi and the Gulf they
were pulling in about two hundred and
forty thousand dollars a day for
security operations in the hurricane
zone at a time when there was a scandal
over two thousand dollar debit cards for
people who were internally displaced
that figure you used four billion
dollars on security in Iraq right is
that four billion dollars spent by the
US government yes that's uh that's
according to representative Henry Waxman
that's something that came out of the
initial hearing he held on Blackwater On
February 7th in the Oversight Committee
so these are taxpayer dollars oh yeah
absolutely so how does the taxpayer know
that he's getting his money's worth put
aside whether it's a good or a bad thing
how do you know you're getting your
money's worth you don't and that's and
that's a major controversy in Congress
right now representative jan Schakowsky
who's on the the Select Intelligence
Committee since 2004 when I've been
talking to her about this issue of
contractors she's been trying to get
information just tell me how many
contractors there are in Iraq tell me
how many contracts we have in excess of
five million dollars tell me how many
have been killed tell me now how many
have been wounded tell me how many
investigations are open at the Justice
Department no answers to any of these
questions and so for years you have
several Congress people some of them in
influential positions who have been
unable to get any information about the
operations of these companies that's
starting to change but it took Henry wax
and since the Fallujah ambush happened
of those Blackwater guys he's been
investigating this one contract he
started aggressively doing it in
November of 2004
it took him until February 7th 2007 to
just get an answer as to whose contract
that ultimately was and it turns out it
was a COS subcontract with KBR and so
now KBR is being forced to give back to
the federal government 20 million
dollars for unauthorized use of security
services in Iraq and they inform their
shareholders that they may have to
return as much as 400 million dollars if
the army continues its investigation I
think earlier you used a figure 100,000
right security consultants know there's
100,000 private contractors that drives
all the KBR right and then of the
military contractors maybe a fifth of
that 100,000 are engaged in military
type activities so that would include
for instance CBS hires a security firm
in Iraq to protect its staff that they
would be included in the hundred
thousand but not in the twenty thousand
right the well I actually don't know how
that works because the the one hundred
thousand figure comes from the
Department of Defense census but even
the Department of Defense has said that
it it's it's not quite sure how accurate
that is and a lot of independent
analysts say it's bigger the Government
Accountability Office says there are 48
thousand employees of private military
firms and of those some senior people in
Congress say that about twenty to
twenty-five thousand are engaged in
active military operations when a
company like CBS hires private security
it would be unclear do they come out of
that pool or do they come out of the
pool of private security contractors
that aren't on government contract for
instance KBR hires Blackwater outside of
its government work to protect its
office and do force protection so it's
unclear I mean this is but the fact that
you a that you ask it is interesting
because it's like a Wild West atmosphere
over there the Times of London said that
the the the war boom in Iraq is not oil
but security how did you get interested
in Blackwater I first went to Iraq in in
1998 and it was the first of many trips
that I would take to Iraq I went in and
out of the country from 98 until 2003
when the occupation began and I actually
had spent time in Fallujah in fact in
the summer of 2002 I camped out in
Fallujah which now would be you know
unthinkable thing
I used to play Domino's on al-rasheed
Street in in Baghdad which you know
you'd be insane to step foot on our
she'd Street as a as a white American
and and and so and I knew many people in
Fallujah and and knew that city well it
was a beautiful city they called it the
city of mosques and it was I you know I
I had something in my heart for the city
of Fallujah and so when when this ambush
happened of these Blackwater guys I paid
very close attention to it and when the
siege of Fallujah happened and we saw
the suffering play out I started to say
oh I mean the the deaths of four private
military contractors was worth the life
of an entire city and that began the
process of looking into them when I
really realized how serious of a story
it was though was in New Orleans when
you see guys who two weeks earlier had
just been in Iraq all of a sudden
deploying on the streets of an American
city heavily armed as though they were
in Iraq I just thought oh this is
unbelievable and